so i'm actually a little nervous by so
many companies saying hey turns out
we're highly functional by
not having an office let's just abandon
the office um
you know people are tribal animals we're
social animals we need human interaction
and at the end of the day um though we
can be functional and get things done
it's very very hard to have any kind of
brainstorming and creativity
uh over like this we need to be in the
company of others we need to be able to
interrupt each other and write things on
walls and and and have that wonderful
magical energy and then go for lunch
together to build a relationship
i mean i've been running a virtual
company for
for over a decade now and i'll tell you
for companies who want to abandon their
office
and go virtual it is way more work
to try and build and maintain trust and
relationships when you don't have an
office it is
much much much it's a much heavier lift
and i think a lot of leaders
underestimate that
one and i think people are also
misinterpreting like twitter for example
announced that they're uh they're
considering work at home forever
but that doesn't mean they're banning
their office but they actually said that
if
people would like to work at home
sometimes we
will maintain that policy forever in
other words what they're allowing is for
options
and if i were to imagine ford's what
could happen to the physical office
if we give people the option to work
from home whenever they want as opposed
to
asking permission for next thursday if i
can work from home
but rather hey i'm working from home
today just because i woke up and didn't
want to go to the office
that that fluidity and that choice makes
us happier
what i if i would have imagined what the
office would look like
i think corporate headquarters will
become a thing of the past we don't have
15 quarters
headquarters in every city kind of thing
but rather
the wework model will become more
popular we're already starting to see
that large companies facebook microsoft
are buying huge memberships to
organizations like we work
and so i could imagine i could imagine a
skyscraper
filled with large companies that are
overflow offices because it's
it's it's a better way for them to
maintain these these open work spaces
for people to come and go as they please
um but i i do not think it's the end of
the office
because human beings crave each other so
much and as we've all learned we miss
our friends and we miss our colleagues
[Music]
you